all right welcome to the live stream I'm
going to be talking about the latest
healthcare disaster yet again it appears
as though Republicans will fail at least
for now to repeal the Affordable Care
Act a major campaign promise of Donald
Trump I'm gonna get into all the details
I will also be taking your questions via
super chat more in a moment you might
notice that there's a new painting on
the wall from the last time that I did
the live stream just a little something
I painted over the weekend no I'm
kidding it's actually it's a real actual
painting that some real artists made but
you don't care about that we're here to
talk about health care and Mitch
McConnell and Donald Trump if this is
your first live stream I will let you
know that it's really live I'm really
doing this right now and talking to you
right now assuming it's 6:30 p.m.
Eastern Time on June 27th if it's some
other time you may be watching a replay
of the live stream number two super chat
is on you can use the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window to send
questions comments I will address them I
will answer questions and respond to
comments super chat is on by all means
use it
number three new members and patrons who
sign up during the live stream I will
thank you live on the stream I will sing
your praises live on the stream because
that is how the program is funded so you
can find out more about membership at
david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show for
information about patreon and please
don't troll ok obvious trolling and hate
it's just gonna get you blocked there
are a number of moderators scanning the
chat and if indeed they identify obvious
trolling or hate they will just block
you or they may time you out for five
minutes it's really up to them they've
been fully deputized by me to do what
they feel they need to do to keep the
chat
under control subtle trolling probably
won't get you banned because it probably
won't even get noticed okay so that is
that and we will jump into the super
chat in a little bit and into new member
thank-yous and all of that stuff but
let's talk about what's going on with
the Republican health care bill so
backstory I don't even know where to
start between World War one and World
War two for lack of a better place to
start this for-profit employer connected
health care system sort of became fully
ingrained in the United States and there
was a time there as wendell potter
writes in his book deadly spin and i've
interviewed him about this there was a
moment in the united states between sort
of after at the end of World War 1
before World War two where it was
feasible it was possible that the United
States would go with a more European
model a single-payer type model or
government health care type model but at
the time the proposal that was floating
around the United States simply sounded
too much like what was being done in
Germany and at the time of course
Germany was our adversary and partially
because of the optics the United States
decided to go in a different direction
skip to the 1990s I mean this is like
the most compressed history of health
care in the United States right skip to
the 1990s and at that point you saw a
conservative think-tanks proposed this
idea of a mandate that was really now as
part of Obamacare is portrayed as this
left-wing extreme left-wing thing but
the reality is that it's pretty
conservative it's pretty pro-business to
say hey here's an idea
the government will mandate that
citizens buy a product from for-profit
companies on which profit is made
somehow as part of Obamacare the right
has denounced that as right-wing but
it's actually a conservative idea from
the 1990s okay we get Obamacare tens of
millions of new customers are given to
these for-profit insurance companies is
it a panacea no by no means we should
have single-payer we should
had a public option we didn't get any of
it the reality is that Obamacare is a
slightly less conservative tweak to what
we had before Obamacare passed
Republicans hate it
Trump hates it blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
so now you have a situation where Donald
Trump runs on repealing and replacing
the Affordable Care Act he made promises
like everybody will be covered costs
won't go up coverage won't go down
quality of care won't go down he won and
now they have a problem and the problem
is that most people like the Obamacare
provisions right most people like can't
be charged outrageous fees if you have
pre-existing conditions most people like
26 year old you can stay on your
parent's insurance up to age 26
most people like there are what we call
sort of essential services medical
services that are covered for everybody
with no copay most people like your
annual physical has no co-payment people
like most of these things what don't
people like people don't like the
personal mandate and people don't like
the employer mandate and they don't like
those because they feel like if the
government telling them they have to buy
a product but what many of those people
don't understand is without those
mandates and without the taxes on the
very rich to cover part of the costs
none of it works none of it works
because you have what's called a risk
pool and you have actuaries that figure
out what's the total amount of money
that needs to come in it's a very
elaborate mathematical field and without
the mandate and the taxes on the rich
none of it works so what's the problem
now we had American Health Care Act
proposal number one CBO scored at twenty
four million people were gonna lose
health care coverage and premiums maybe
would go down slightly after ten years
maybe they wouldn't okay fails miserably
Donald Trump ends up sort of stepping
back and saying he wasn't really
involved even though Paul Ryan said
Trump was involved blah blah blah blah
blah now we've got American Health Care
Act proposal number two passes the house
about a month ago they passed it before
the CBO even scores it because it was
going to be a disaster scoring from the
CBO see
Oh scores it a couple of days later they
say 23 million people are gonna lose
coverage over the next 10 years go from
24 million people losing coverage to 23
million people losing coverage we don't
hear anything about it for a month
partially because it's scandal after
scandal after scandal for Donald Trump
finally the Senate takes it up and the
Senate says we're gonna modify it we're
gonna improve upon version 2 of the
houses American Health Care Act we
finally get a scoring from the
Congressional Budget Office and it says
not 24 million people will lose health
care not 23 million people will lose
health care 22 million people will lose
health coverage some because without the
mandate will choose not to have
insurance I don't intend to hide that
from you in any way but 22 million fewer
people will be covered after a decade
disaster Mitch McConnell Senate Majority
Leader says we're gonna vote on this
thing before the before the fourth of
July break we were gonna get this done a
few Republican senators including Susan
Collins of may of Maine rather says yeah
I can't support this I just I'm not
going to support this numerous
Republicans start to come out of the
woodwork saying we're not going to be
able to support this and the breaking
news as of just hours ago is that there
will be no vote in the Senate on the
Republican health care bill before the
July 4th vacation it's just not going to
happen it would not have passed and
Mitch McConnell now has to go back to
the drawing board and Donald Trump
commented he said negotiators are
working on it they're quote getting very
close on a deal that Obamacare is
melting down as we speak and it's all
the same tired talking points that are
being becoming increasingly problematic
for Donald Trump because he ran on a
promise to repeal and replace the
Affordable Care Act he needs to do
something to not suffer the political
repercussions now but if 22 million
people lose their health insurance many
millions of those before the twenty20
re-election potential re-election of
Donald Trump that is going to be another
political problem for Donald Trump and
the problem that you have here is he
promised something that is in
possible this is not Republic this is
not democratic obstruction of this bill
Donald Trump last week tried to blame
Democrats for obstructing this bill in
the Senate at the time Democrats hadn't
even seen the bill the third - other
than the 13 Republicans working on the
bill Republicans hadn't seen the bill so
Donald Trump is trying to frame the
delay in repealing and replacing
Obamacare as Democratic obstruction but
the truth is Republicans have the house
Republicans have the Senate Republicans
have the White House and the reason
they're not getting consensus is that
the promises that were made are
impossible think about it for a second
you can't move to the right if Obamacare
is your starting point without someone
losing Donald Trump promised nobody is
going to have inferior care lose
insurance or have their premiums go up
just think about it for a second if you
Tet if you start with Obamacare which
says you can't charge people more if
they have pre-existing conditions if you
remove that requirement and insurance
companies all of a sudden can charge
people more if they have pre-existing
conditions
that's a capitalist victory right but
some people now won't be able to afford
health insurance so you will have people
who lose their insurance as a result if
you say well okay we're gonna keep the
pre-existing condition aspect of it but
we are going to eliminate the Obamacare
subsidies or reduce them or something
like that okay well some people can no
longer afford health insurance so their
health outcomes are going to be poor and
their ability to afford insurance is
going to go away if you allow companies
to keep costs the same for most people
but you say they don't have to
participate in an Obamacare exchange or
what have you which may have a lower
profit margin well great the profit
margin for these insurance companies
will go out but now you've got people
who might have been able to afford a
plan through the Obamacare exchange and
now no longer can you cannot do
any of the things that the American
Health Care Act seeks to do without some
combination of costs going up coverage
becoming inferior or people no longer
being able to afford and or getting
kicked off of their health insurance you
just can't do it so this is a problem of
over-promising promising something that
is impossible and now having to deal
with the political repercussions of well
I promised I was gonna repeal this thing
and it's not happening but at the same
time if we pass what's been proposed so
far millions of people are gonna lose
their health coverage what's going to
happen what's going to happen and now it
is a serious political issue for
Republicans so I do not feel bad for
Republicans this is a problem of their
own creation this is a problem they
created by four years having these bogus
symbolic votes about repeal Obamacare in
the house and blah blah blah blah blah
even if it had passed it would have
never passed the Senate Barack Obama
would have vetoed it all of a sudden now
they can do it and it is Republicans
that can't agree on how because it will
destroy many of their constituencies
that's the overview okay let's jump into
the super chat we've got a $25 super
chat here from Gerry Sifuentes with no
comment or question Jerry thanks very
much I appreciate the support game fire
74 has sent the $6 and 45 cents uber
chat and of course super chat involves
using the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window
game fire 74 asks shouldn't Mitch
McConnell go back to the Galapagos so he
can be home with his friends and family
will he keep trying to ruin health care
in the United States short answer is yes
game fire that's exactly what Mitch
McConnell is going to try to do he is
going to try to get the votes together
after making some amendments so this
actually I'm glad you're bringing this
up there's a couple of articles out
including one from CNN that I am linking
to in the description to the live stream
where Mitch McConnell says he wants to
make some
Changez and put in some amendments and
have American Health Care Act Senate
version 2 re scored by the Congressional
Budget Office and and again the problem
is unless you do something totally
different like a public option increased
subsidies add taxes on the rich to
offset the costs of health care go in
the direction of single-payer unless you
do that maybe you can get from a twenty
two million dollar CBO I'm sorry a
twenty two million person CBO estimate
of health insurance loss to nineteen
million or eighteen million or seventeen
million you're not going to get more
people covered doing any of the things
that Republicans want to do with this
bill so yes game fire Mitch McConnell is
determined gr has sent a five-dollar
super chat pack D Z there's an amount of
disturbing that I have to make clear
back the story Pakman if there's one
thing you do today back of the story
love gr I have absolutely no idea what
gr is talking about and then gr
following up with another ten dollar
super chat saying if you have a moment
let gr make it clear to that moment that
every moment counts this moment counts I
can't be more clear [ __ ] nasty orange
the man is orange
don't forget love gr all right well
thanks jr. very very much appreciate
that although I can't quite make heads
or tails out of it Frank macwrite has
sent the twenty dollar super chat saying
since it has been proven by the CIA and
others that Russia did indeed meddle in
the election by that fact alone doesn't
it absolutely affect the outcome may be
not votes exactly but surely it's
tainted I don't know that I agree with
you Frank and and I want to be super
clear you know people write to me they
say David you know you're just you're
you're in the tank for I don't even know
who the Dems are someone on this on this
Trump Russia thing and X hasn't been
proven why hasn't been proven and you're
ideologically committed to it I honestly
don't care about pushing a narrative if
it is not backed by fact
so I want a full and complete
investigation to take place into Trump
Russia collusion so we can know the
truth and and then decide what to do
with that I believe that there is no
doubt whatsoever and I did a segment on
the show today about the four paths that
Russia took to attempt to influence the
2016 election whether they of whether
they change the eventual results is a
different question and it's actually not
the key question right now and and I
think that that's where I would sort of
disagree with you Frank which is just
because Russia made numerous attempts to
meddle doesn't mean that the results are
necessarily tainted and once again when
you think about why blood of your Putin
would want Trump
elected right why would Putin want Trump
to be President of the United States
because his weak he's weak he's a
buffoon he's clueless and he's
manipulative in that it's not necessary
that Russia coordinate with Trump
specifically to achieve their desired
outcome it's possible we can imagine
situations where they would do that but
it's not necessary and what I want is to
uncover the truth and what's abundantly
clear is that the Trump team has been
taking many has been making numerous
efforts to obstruct a full and fair
investigation that is what we know and
and hopefully at this point we'll figure
out what the truth actually is DJ Murray
has sent a ten dollar super chat by
using the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window no question or comment
very much appreciate the support
DJ Frank macwrite has sent another
twenty dollar super chat saying would
has been proven to be falsely reported
by CNN MSNBC CBS
oh I'm reading this with the wrong
inflection what has been proven to be
falsely reported by CNN MSNBC CBS and
not been retracted or corrected in other
words has there been any real fake news
that the major news networks are
standing by no and we had this recent
story from CNN
that they were tracted and three people
resigned over but by and large the
reports that we've seen on Trump Russia
from the New York Times from the
Washington Post from numerous media
outlets over time we still have a list
of assertions that are as yet unproven
we have no assertions that have been
disproven and we have a growing list of
assertions that have been proven and I
think that that's a really key point
Frank which is there have been no major
Russian narratives which we've read
about and then found out you know what
it was untrue there's stuff in the
Russian blackmail dossier that has not
yet been proven and maybe it's not does
Donald Trump like to urinate on Russian
prostitutes maybe not it hasn't been
proven but there's been nothing
definitively disproven part of it is the
complexity and difficulty of sometimes
proving negatives and that's something
that we're just going to have to sort of
contend with but over time more and more
aspects of that Russian blackmail file
are corroborated the Michael Flynn stuff
the Michael Cohen stuff on and on and on
so a very very good point Frank but Mark
Stanners has sent a to British pound
super chat with no question or comment I
appreciate that mark so that is we are
caught up on super chats and I will
absolutely get back to those let me say
a few thank-yous to some very very
special people okay we have a program
that is funded mostly by our audience
okay and we used to be funded much more
by YouTube ad revenue because of the
YouTube ad calamity that started on
March March 31st we've lost about
two-thirds of our ad revenue and what
we're doing as a result to try to keep
the program unaffected by that is
talking number one about the david
pakman show membership program this is
something you can sign up for on our web
site at david pakman.com slash
membership it costs as little as six
dollars a month pre discount and as
little as 60 dollars for the year we do
produce an entire extra show every
single day for our paid subscribers it's
called the bonus show members also get
daily full hour commercial free episodes
of the show instead of having to deal
with
the three to seven minute YouTube clips
you get the entire show as one long clip
only members get that and we do have a
coupon code available which is I voted
17 it's all one word and all lowercase
and you can enter that on the second
page of the sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership whenever people sign up
during the live streams I thank them and
talk about what great people they are
and at the top of that list is will
Albert's will Albert's signed up just
minutes into the livestream today and he
opted not to use the coupon code and
again whether you use the coupon code or
not that is not the important thing the
important thing is you sign up and you
pay something because that is how we are
counteracting the YouTube ad boycott
will Albert's opted to get a level 2
monthly membership at $12 a month and I
really really appreciate that
Klaus rhymers klaus rhymer
has signed up for a $60 a year
membership opting to use the coupon code
dropping it down to just $36 for the
entire year
ok Gerard O'Neill Gerard O'Neill has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership for 6 dollars a month Gerard
thank you thank you so much for signing
up and lastly Christian Adrianna's mere
man's has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership opting not to use the
coupon code and that is a really really
great thing that Christian has done now
if the entire membership thing feels
like too much or it's too expensive or
you just want to watch the YouTube clips
but you want to send us a couple bucks
there is another option and that option
is to go to patreon and you can go to
patreon.com/scishow we have surpassed
the 1,500 patron mark and for that we
can all be very very grateful and you
can make a contribution even as little
as a dollar a month you can do at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
and that is very very much appreciated
you will also get a thank you even if
you don't think for a second that if you
can only contribute $1 a month I will
not thank you live on the stream
I will folks believe me believe me let's
jump back into the super chats because
we've got more action there gr has sent
a $10 super chat saying Pakman I insist
you speak aloud of the nonsense the
nonsense DZ only if you want also
Rodrigo Clarke is an O I F vet and would
love a comment on the VA nonsense
love grps you flow supreme okay I'm I
can tell part of this is a compliment
although I can't tell exactly what it is
about but I'm gonna keep trying to
figure it out gr thank you and gr
following up with it with I believe is
4th super chat of the evening saying
veterans you are me be heard through my
voice Trump is a liar Trump is a coward
you are not cowards you are champions of
spirits as champions of spirit and
courage gr really knows his way around
the English language and really a
message of support to the veterans and a
message that I echo and can absolutely
get behind and it looks like Frank
macwrite is now explaining what the
Rodrigo Clark super chat or message is
saying I'm a disabled Oh i f veteran
Trump recently wanted to get individual
get rid of individual unemployability
and needed veterans benefit please talk
about how fake Republicans and Trump are
towards veterans please oh my god I mean
I've been talking for years Rodrigo and
thanks Frank and gr for facilitating
that question from Rodrigo I've been
talking for years about how the meme of
support the troops from Republicans for
years has really been quite the opposite
when I think about what does it mean to
support the troops it means listen we
are lucky enough in the United States to
have enough volunteer members of the
military that we don't need to have a
draft
despite in fact the incredible number of
military engagements
we have chosen to engage our troops in
even considering that we have so many
veterans willing to volunteer active
duty and veterans who were willing to
bought volunteer at the time that we
don't need a draft so when I say oh
let's take care of the troops what I
mean is let's make sure that we only
risk the lives of our troops when it is
truly absolutely necessary that means
not going to into optional Wars for
dirty fossil fuels that we should have
gotten rid of years ago that means not
ignoring issues of sexual assault
against both male and female members of
the military that means taking care of
our veterans when they come back and
taking seriously issues like PTSD and
taking seriously the veteran and what's
going on there that support the troops
to me support the troops to me is not
whenever the president says we're going
to war somewhere or lately doesn't say
it but just does it behind our backs to
put a yellow ribbon on my car and say
that I support the mission no matter
what because I'm a patriot that's not
supporting the troops Oh Roderigo thank
you for your service you were absolutely
right point well made and and I wish we
we had more of that being discussed but
we just don't gain fire 74 is following
up with a an $11 and 39 cent super chat
asking pretend Trump is impeached
removed from power and jailed because
that makes me happy what kind of damage
would that do to the Republican Party
what happened to Republic related to
what happened to Republicans after
Watergate maybe here's the thing okay
and this is why it's so dangerous for
Democrats not to build a campaign of
issues a platform of issues now and
really it should have been six months
ago but now is a better time the best
time would have been six months ago the
second best time is right now if Donald
Trump is going in the direction of
impeachment and his approval rating goes
down even more
it's not like Republicans are gonna go
down with the ship you will see
Republicans start to distance themselves
and so yeah there will probably be some
Republicans who will be inextricably
linked to Donald Trump but some won't
and that's why it is really dangerous to
assume that if Trump goes down or if
Trump's approval rating remains really
low it's bad for all Republicans if
Trump's approval rating remains in the
high 30s you'll probably see most
Republicans stick with them and because
of gerrymandering and voter suppression
a lot of them will be reelected in 2018
however if Donald Trump's approval
rating keeps dipping you'll start to see
Republicans jump ship and you already
are seeing approach from super PAC
target some Republicans who have not
been as friendly to Donald Trump it's
already happening so whatever the
progressive strategy is to the extent
that the Democrats are interested in
being progressive and that's a whole
other issue with its own set of
questions none of the strategy can
depend on Republicans self-destructing
if they do that by putting forth by
getting approved and passed and enacted
a health care bill that will lead to 22
million people losing health insurance
Democrats could consider that a bonus
and try to as quickly as possible fix it
to get people covered once again but you
we cannot be depending on Republicans
being irreversibly damaged by whatever
it is that Donald Trump does it just it
does not work that way and I would be
very very concerned about Democrats
continuing to do that let me get caught
up on membership thank-yous as I
mentioned earlier the program is mostly
funded by members and by patrons
membership happens at david pakman.com
slash membership where you can read
about all of the many many many member
benefits and just what we've been
chatting here we've had a number of
additional members sign up I want to say
a big thank you to Nick Gutierrez who
has signed up Nick thank you I want to
say thank you to James Newman James
Newman has signed up at david pakman.com
slash members that
membership I want to say thank you to
Christine Jaeger Christine Jaeger has
signed up using no less the 40% discount
coupon code which is I voted 17 and a
major major thank you
I when I see this it is just absolutely
tremendous Frederick Harris has just
signed up for a level 4 yearly
membership that's uh that's what we call
the big boy in the office four hundred
and eighty dollars for the year our our
our biggest league single payment
membership and I really really
appreciate that and and you know what
even the people who are donating a
dollar a month at patreon.com slash
David Pakman show you were just as
appreciated as those who have larger
financial resources available to support
the show and on that note I should
mention we've surpassed the 1500 patron
mark at patreon.com slash david pakman
show if and when we get to 2,000 patrons
i have already committed to doing an
entire broadcast show in our studio
which will go out to our 200 radio and
television stations i will do an entire
broadcast show with my hair like this
and you know you're probably used to
seeing my hair more under control the
way it is right now and the way that
that's achieved is is with the
introduction of a little bit of product
into my hair without it this is what
happens okay and this is a scary sight
to many many children and i probably
should have done it with some kind of
warning before putting this up on the
screen but I will be doing an entire
broadcast show at the studio if and when
we get to 2,000 patreon patrons and that
is something you can look into and no I
was not by any means under the influence
of any of
narcotic psychedelics of any kind people
talking about my pupils look dilated
here they don't my pupils are not
dilated maybe in the picture they're
sort of blending with the green part of
my eye but I assure you this was taken I
was of sound mind at the time I guess is
what I'm saying
scary sight scary sight for many let me
tell you a little more about what's
gonna be on the program tomorrow so we
are absolutely going to be digging into
in even more detail to what we talked
about today the yet again another
failure another delay for the Republican
health care plan this time it's version
two of the American Health Care Act now
delayed in the Senate Mitch McConnell
demanding a vote before the fourth of
July recess they have three days left it
is not going to happen it is just not
going to happen I read a very
interesting statement from Elizabeth
Warren where Elizabeth Warren is now
saying Democrats should campaign on
single-payer health care I've had my
critiques of Elizabeth Warren recently
and she was recently interviewed by Jen
Kyogre of The Young Turks and he asked
her straight up and I've got a clip
about this you can check out why didn't
you choose if if you are most
ideologically aligned with Bernie
Sanders senator Warren why didn't you
choose to support Bernie Sanders during
the primary phase of the 2016 election
and Elizabeth Warren basically did a
non-answer totally bogus non-answer I
didn't like it a lot of progressives
didn't like it I've also been saying for
several weeks months now that Democrats
need to really it's progressives within
the Democratic Party to the extent that
they exist Democrats need to pick some
issues and really go forward with a
platform that is independent of we're
not Trump
we're not Republicans and I listed
health care at the top of my list and
while I don't believe that under the
current Republican controlled House and
Senate we would even have a shot at
single-payer health care Democrats
should be talking about health care for
all they can talk about HR 676 if they
want they can talk about
they'll pay health care as an ideal and
maybe you end up negotiating to
something else but you've got to be
talking about everybody needs to be
covered essential health benefits
covered period everybody's got to be
covered and now elizabeth warren is
saying hey what about Democrats making
single-payer healthcare part of their
part of their platform part of the plan
for 2018 and 2020 and I agree with her
and I am not the type of person that I'm
not like Trump where I say oh either
you're the best person or you're a bad
person I disagree with some things
Elizabeth with Elizabeth Warren on some
issues I agree with her on other issues
and I think that this is something that
she is absolutely right on and we need
to be talking about pollution and the
climate as an issue of nationalism and
patriotism because the left is already
going to support dealing with that and
that might be a narrative that appeals
to the right a little bit more I I've
outlined the entire thing and I'm gonna
dig back into it tomorrow
okay I also want to talk about a
narrative that we have now seen on Fox
News in a couple places you we've seen a
Fox commentator as well as Sean Hannity
over the last 24 hours start testing a
new narrative on Trump Russia which is
even if Trump colluded with Russia it's
not against the law
the fact that we are seeing numerous
right-wing media programs shift tone
from collusion with Russia no evidence
Democratic witch-hunt
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah we're not
seeing that as much anymore we're seeing
Donald Trump shift to okay there was
collusion but it's Obama's fault because
he didn't prevent it and it's actually
Obama who did the colluding with Russia
that is now correlating timewise with
this this new idea from at least a
couple programs on Fox News of nothing
illegal even if we find out Trump
colluded there's nothing illegal and
that is a shift that is meaningful that
is a shift that clearly relates to the
changing evidence that has been
surfacing and I want to talk about that
because I believe that that is
absolutely a strategy that is a strategy
that we are seeing now
from the right let me jump back into the
super chat mark Stanners has sent a five
British pound super chap in the UK
liberal is Center ground politically and
the NHS is great why are these ideas so
bad in the United States it's not just
the UK I mean in in many countries what
is considered far left in the u.s. is
basically middle-of-the-road or center
left and what is uncontroversial like oh
yeah everybody gets health care paid
through their taxes and you can work
wherever you want or not and you still
get health care that's considered
controversial and communist or socialist
in the u.s. it's not just in the UK mark
that it's that it's not controversial
and it is a very important point which
is the Overton Window of what's
considered reasonable debate in the
United States is shifted very very far
to the right compared to in many other
countries gr is sending a $10 Super chat
saying truth hurts I don't know where to
begin
there is a line for your name you could
have fought with us but you hid in shame
our names went on the line where'd you
sign thanks DZ love gr I have no idea
what that's about I don't know what it
is that was signed or not signed or
whatever the case may be
I don't get it gr but I do appreciate
the super chats and I do appreciate the
support okay my main thing today was
going to be the health care bill which
has failed we've talked about that I am
going to I need to spend some time
actually preparing for tomorrow's show
so we are cutting today's stream here
thanks to everybody who chatted thanks
to everybody who signed up and pledged
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and david pakman.com slash membership
and I will leave you with this I will do
a show with my hair like this in studio
if and only if we get to 2000 patreon
patrons doesn't matter the amount just
2,000 patrons check it out at
patreon.com slash david pakman show link
in the description for the live stream